Movistar states you behind the scenes of
the latest los estudios movie Avengers
infinity war here we go
[Music]
Ventures of Smarties through
was it like being under it's kind of
surreal because there's so many of us
now okay by the way doctor strange
reason to meet up Miyabi spider-man I
[Music]
didn't look very heroic and everyone
looked really cool we got to see a new
side in Ibaka it's a new gadgets
[Music]
everybody's Charlie so the Disney
Channel released a new preview there's
only Genki quality versions of this like
unless you really watch the Disney
Channel all the time you're probably
gonna miss it because they don't post
them online but it's actually a pretty
good preview so there's a bunch of new
footage of him before they go into outer
space especially him saving Iron Man so
I'll break this down but if you aren't
finding me for the first time it's the
weekend so there's a new round of that
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all you have
to do to enter that just be a subscriber
and leave an Avengers related comment on
the video the footage itself is better
than what Tom Holland says about it so
he just says like the general oh this is
gonna be cool I'm gonna have a new suit
some new gadgets he's talking about his
iron spider gadgets we all know what's
going on with that I've actually seen
more detailed pictures of the suits
functionality but I do think that it's
kind of spoilery so I'm not gonna
include it in this video if you've ever
read a comic book with the iron spider
costume you know exactly what's going on
but I know a couple people still want
like some surprises so there are a
couple pictures that I'm probably not
going to include when I do videos but we
get a little bit more footage of him
swinging around New York City before he
goes to help Iron Man and Doctor Strange
out at the sanctum you see him swinging
with this piece of tech here you have to
imagine that the black order lands that
ship above New York City to come for the
time stone and just start wrecking
everything
so spider-man swings in to help but
separately all the other Avengers have
been inside the sanctum and they walk
out to probably the coolest part of this
though is that you see spider-man using
his webbing to swing part of a car that
has been chopped in half like you see
this taxicab it's literally just the
back of the taxicab that he's swinging
with his webbing it landed right on top
of coal obsidian as he's getting ready
to smash Iron Man with his hammer and if
there was anybody that wasn't sure about
how strong spider-man was after Captain
America Civil War
he literally catches coal obsidians
hammer as he's swinging it although I
don't think this is a full-strength
swing but I do love the idea that
spider-man saves Iron Man obviously it
comes before that moment where they go
onto the ship but he gets the iron
spider costume and he dubs him an
Avenger all right kid you're an Avenger
now the quality's kind of janky but you
can kind of see part of Iron Man's new
bleeding-edge armor sticking out the
back he has those special wings and
we've seen a couple other trailer shots
of him flying around with all this
debris you get a really funny shot of
them on that cue ship with the guardians
of the galaxy so Spider Man meets
star-lord but he has them in this kind
of like faux headlock like who the hell
are you
we're The Avengers man and then you get
the Thor clip where he says Earth's
Mightiest Heroes so obviously that's a
different scene what I think is
happening here is that in the timeline
of the movie the guardians meet Thor
first in space then Thor tells them
about Thanos star-lord and half of them
split off and go to earth Thor probably
takes off with rocket and teenage Groot
to the space Forge to make his new
weapon so when star-lord is meeting
spider-man here is after he's met Thor
and Thor told him to go back to earth so
there's not all the guardians here but
you get a much better shot of the
collectors workshop which I'm guessing
is still on knowhere because there was a
scene that I posted a while ago where
Thanos is coming for the reality stone
and he asked the collector where is it
like he has his foot on his chest here
the guardians are sneaking in but you
don't see any of the other Avengers and
it seems like they don't all meet back
up again until they get back on Titan so
I'll talk about that in a second but the
thing about the collectors workshop here
is this is obviously just the sound
stages like a behind the scenes the
footage we've seen of it is basically in
ruin you see like Gamora looking like
she's getting ready to cry is either
she's crying because Thanos has one of
the other gems or because she's just
upset about all the destruction but this
funny shot of Loki busking behind scene
just dancing around is obviously still
on the as guardianship like some of
these backgrounds you can kind of
distinguish which ship they're on like
this is on the cue ship when he's with
spider-man this is on the Asgardian ship
when you with Loki Thor's on the
guardianship we've seen a whole bunch of
footage of that if you didn't remember
to Tom Holland also talks about their
first day on set and how he felt like a
total douche because he was in a mocap
suit and everybody else was in like a
really cool superhero costume iron man's
like hey welcome to the club kid because
he walks around in a mocap suit for a
lot of his scenes too but you remember
almost a year and a half ago they
released a preview video from day 1 of
infinity where like they literally had
just rolled cameras on the first day and
released a special preview like hey this
is what's coming it's gonna be really
awesome
but it was mostly behind the scenes he
just saw a little bit of green screen
now we know that this was the Titan set
because we gotten all the footage but
the funny thing is is it like this big
battle that we've been seeing them
fighting Thanos most of it's been in the
trailers is that that's like the very
first thing that they shot this is our
first day here we are in Pinewood in
Atlanta and it's it's actually pretty
unbelievable day one of what promises to
be a year of fun-filled lensing I think
the reason why they did that is one
because they wanted to include some
trailer footage of that and it was gonna
take a long time to do the special
effects so they needed to start extra
early so like a lot of times James Gunn
says that when he's planning his movies
out he tries to think about what the
trailer for the movie is actually gonna
look like so as a director it helps you
structure some of the way that you shoot
things
so obviously infinity war has been in
planning for so long now that they're
like okay well obviously we got to have
a battle with Thanos in the trailer so
we're gonna have to start shooting that
real early so why don't we just do that
first because there's not a lot of
dialogue usually it's easier to do
scenes like that where you don't have to
write pages and pages of big long
speeches it's like Tom Horn joked that
they never told him who he was fighting
when they were on this set they're just
like you're fighting this big guy here
you're swinging around like you can see
him pulling on these strings
those are like reference points for his
webbing so it's fun to watch them
actually make this you get a sense for
what it's like day-to-day on screen
sometimes when they're doing stuff like
this it's totally crazy and it doesn't
make any sense other times it's like
these funny moments where Thor is
meeting the guardians and trying to win
them over it's a more traditional scene
where it's just like them talking to
each other but you get one more last big
shot of him in his iron spider costume
and it looks like he's still inside the
queue ship so this looks like pretty
early in the film so obviously this is
all cut out of order but just let me
know in the comments what's your
favorite part about this and what do you
think happens when the guardians first
come back and meet spider-man Iron Man
Doctor Strange in the other earth-based
Avengers because what it sounds like
happens is is that everybody sort of
cross paths briefly then they go their
separate ways then they all meet back up
either in Wakanda or on Titan and then
you have the end of the movie
they start to converge again before
Avengers for the directors have been
doing more interviews they talked a
little bit about Avengers 4 in
thematically how it fits in with all
these other Marvel movies they say it's
like the culmination of an arc that
started during Winter Soldier I was
gonna do a video about that before all
this footage drop so I might do that
tomorrow but I'm expecting more of this
stuff to just kind of drop throughout so
if you have any special requests while
I'm doing videos like this just let me
know in the comments below I have gotten
a lot more requests to do videos for the
Black Order what will probably happen as
we get closer we'll start to see little
bits of them more and more in the TV
spots and trailers that they drop what
I'll probably do for like really special
characters like Hawkeye ant-man and the
wasp or like you know people that were
still wandering about in the movie is
I'll just wait for like a really good
piece of footage for them to talk about
them because like ant-man is a good
example they released a promo on the
Japanese Twitter account for Avengers
with his costume that said it was used
during infinity war so it's like wait a
minute if they used ant-man's costume
during infinity war does that mean that
he's an infinity war there's just like a
number of little things that sort of
like give you an idea for what's going
on in the background but like Hawkeye
definitely a background character on a
mission probably has something to do
with Nick Fury so don't worry we'll talk
about Hawkeye and all those missing
characters soon there's a funny new
Deadpool video that I want to post
there's a new flash so I'll try to
figure out what's gonna happen next I'll
post updates on my Twitter account you
can follow me on Twitter I'll post the
link in that top pin comment but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Adams iller please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details click
here for that secret Ward's video and
click here for the Deadpool trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]